.
MIGUEL MARCEZ IS STANDING BY
LIVE.
LET'S GO TO THE NEWS
CORRESPONDENCE.
>> YOU SEE SEVERAL SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS FROM THE UNIFIED
COMMAND WHO INTRODUCED
THEMSELVES MOMENTARILY.
THESE INDIVIDUALS REPRESENT ONLY
A SMALL FRACTION OF THE MANY
DEDICATED PROFESSIONALS WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK ON THIS COMPLEX
RESPONSE EFFORT.
WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TIME FOR THE
FAMILIES OF THE MISSING CREW
MEMBERS ABOARD THE TITAN AND OUR
THOUGHTS GO OUT TO THEM AND THE
CREW.
THE UNIFIED COMMAND TEAM IS
WORKING TIRELESSLY TO BRING ALL
AVAILABLE ASSETS AND EXPERTISE
TO BEAR AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
IN RESPONSE TO THIS COMPLEX
OPERATION.
WE REMAIN IN CLOSE CONTACT GO
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBERS AND THE
CREW TO ENSURE THEY'RE FULLY
AWARE OF OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
SEARCH EFFORTS.
ADDITIONALLY, WE'VE MADE CLOSE
CONTACT WITH THE BRITISH AND
FRENCH CONSULATES GENERAL TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE FULLY APRICED
OF OUR EFFORTS.
WE'RE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
INTERNATIONAL ASSISTANCE THAT
HAS BEEN PROVIDED INCLUDING AN
EXPERT SUB MARINER FROM THE
ROYAL NAVY WHO IS HERE WITH US
SERVING ABOARD AS A CRITICAL
MEMBER OF OUR TEAM.
ADDITIONALLY, A TEAM OF HIGHLY
FIF TEAMS ARE EN ROUTE TO AID IN
THE SEARCH MORE OVER, OUR
CANADIAN PARTNERS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING CRITICAL LEADERSHIP
AND SIGNIFICANT RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF OUR EFFORTS.
AGAIN, THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX SEARCH OPERATION
REQUIRING SURFACE AND SUBSURFACE
ELEMENTS.
AND OUR UNIFIED APPROACH IS
CRITICAL.
THE LOCATION OF THE SEARCH, 900
MILES EAST OF CAPE COD AND 400
MILES SOUTHEAST OF ST. JOHN'S
MAKES VERY DIFFICULT TO MOBILIZE
LARGE AMOUNTS OF EQUIPMENT
QUICKLY.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE AIR
AND SURFACE SEARCH ASSETS TO
SEARCH BELOW THE SURFACE.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE SERVICE
ASSETS SEARCHING FOR THE "TITAN"
AND WE EXPECT TEN TO SURFACE IN
THE NEXT FEW HOURS.
THERE ARE TWO ROVs ACTIVELY
SXECHING TWO MORE ARE EN ROUTE.
WE'VE RECEIVED INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT WITH AVIATION ASSETS
FROM OUR COAST GUARD AIR STATION
IN ELIZABETH CITY, THE AIR
NATIONAL GUARD AND CANADIAN
ARMED FORCES.
TODAY THERE ARE TWO BACK TO BACK
P-3 FLIGHTS.
ONE IS ONGOING NOW TOTALING 14
HOURS OF CONTINUOUS ONSCENE
COVERAGE AND TWO C-130 COVERAGE
ALL THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND INTO
THE EVENING.
YESTERDAY THE CANADIAN P-3
DETECTED UNDERWATER NOISES IN
THE SEARCH AREA.
AS A RESULT, ROV OPERATIONS WERE
RELOCATED IN AN ATTEMPT TO
EXPLORE THE ORIGIN OF THE
NOISES.
ALTHOUGH THE ROV HAS NOT GOTTEN
RESULTS, THEY CONTINUE.
ADDITIONALLY IT HAS BEEN SHARED
WITH OUR U.S. NAVY EXPERTS FOR
FURTHER ANALYSIS WHICH WILL BE
CONSIDERED IN FUTURE SEARCH
PLANS.
THE SURFACE SEARCH IS NOW
APPROXIMATELY TWO TIMES THE SIZE
OF CONNECTICUT AND IT IS UP TO
TWO AND A HALF MILES DEEP.
EXPONENTIALLY EXPANDING THE SIZE
OF THE SEARCH AREA.
WE HAVE TO FACTOR IN EVER
CHANGING WEATHER CONDITIONS,
CURRENTS AND SEA STATES THAT
EXPAND THE THE SEARCH AREA EVERY
HOUR.
THERE IS AN ENORMOUS COMPLEXITY
WITH THIS CASE DUE TO IT BEING
SO FAR OFFSHORE AND THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN MULTIPLE
AGENCIES AND NATIONS.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT AND OFFERS
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT.
THE UNIFIED COMMAND CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE ASSETS AND RESOURCES
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE BEST
CAPABILITY IN THE MOST TIMELY
MANNER.
THIS INCLUDES WEIGHING MULTIPLE
FACTORS TO IDENTIFY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
THE RESPONSE OPERATION.
WITH CAREFUL CONSIDERATION TO
TIMELINESS OF EQUIPMENT ARRIVING
ON SCENE, USEFULNESS AND ABILITY
TO DELIVER ASSETS TO THE SEARCH
AREA.
OVER THE PAST 48 HOURS, WE HAVE
THROUGH INCREDIBLE UNIT OF
EFFORT MOBILIZED AND IMPLEMENTED
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
EXPERTISE.
IN ADDITION TO THE SHIPS AND
AIRCRAFT PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
WE'VE DISPATCHED TWO SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS.
THEY WILL SERVE AS SEARCH
COORDINATORS ON SCENE FOR
UNDERWATER OPERATIONS.
SO I'VE BEEN STRESSING UNITY OF
EFFORT A LOT IN THIS STATEMENT
AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO THIS
COMPLEX OPERATION.
AGAIN, OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYER
ARE WITH THE CREW OF THE "TITAN"
AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
WE WILL WORK AS HARD AND QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE IN AN EFFORT TO
LOCATE THEM.
I WILL TAKE A FEW QUESTIONS.
BEFORE I DO THAT, I'M GOING TO
HAVE EACH OF THE MEMBERS, THE
TEAM, INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND
I'LL TAKE SOME QUESTIONS.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M PAUL HANKINS.
I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR SALVAGE
OPERATIONS WITH THE U.S. NAVY'S
SUPERVISOR OF SALVAGE.
>> HELLO, I'M CARL FROM THE
OCEANOGRAPHIC INSTITUTE.
>> I'M AN EXCHANGE OFFICER
CURRENTLY SERVING ON THE STAFF
AT NORFOLK, VIRGINIA.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
LIEUTENANT COMMANDER CHRISTIE
BUTLER WORKING CLOSELY WITH
FREDERICK.
[ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ]
>> SO A COUPLE THING.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
SEARCH AND RESCUE, YOU ALWAYS
HAVE HOPE.
THAT'S WHY WE DO WHAT WE DO.
WITH RESPECT TO THE NOISES, WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TO BE
FRANK WITH YOU.
THE P-3 DETECTED NOISES.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE DOING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THAT'S WHY THEY PUT SONAR IN THE
WATER.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE'RE
SEARCHING IN THE AREA WHERE THE
NOISES WERE DETECTED AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO DO SO.
AND WE HOPE THAT WHEN WE'RE ABLE
TO GET ADDITIONAL ROVs WHICH
WILL GET THERE IN THE MORNING,
THE INTENT WILL BE TO SEARCH IN
THOSE AREAS WHERE THE NOISES
WERE DETECTED.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO BE DETECTED,
AND THEN PUT ADDITIONAL ROVs
WHERE THE SEARCH WAS ORIGINALLY
TAKING PLACE.
I HADN'T HEARD 30-MINUTE
INTERVALS.
HERE'S WHAT I CAN TELL YOU.
SO I AM NOT A TRAINED EAR FOR
UNDERWATER AQUATICS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A TEAM OF
EXPERTS ANALYZING THAT DATA.
IT WAS SENT IMMEDIATELY TO THE
NAVY LAST NIGHT AND IT WAS
ANALYZED OVERNIGHT.
THEY'RE STILL LOOKING AT IT.
INCONCLUSIVE.
I THINK THE IMPORTANT PIECES.
WE'RE SEARCHING IN THE AREA
WHERE THE NOISES WERE DETECTED.
>> CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE TIME
LINE?
>> A TIME LINE IN WHAT RESPECT?
OH, OKAY.
SO IN TERMS OF, WE TALKED ABOUT
THE ACTION NUMBER.
I THINK THERE'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
THE OXYGEN, THAT'S JUST ONE
PIECE OF DATA.
RIGHT?
THERE ARE A LOT OF PIECES OF
DATA THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER.
AND WE'RE CONTINUOUSLY LOOKING
AT THAT AND WE'RE CONTINUOUSLY
DOING THAT THROUGHOUT THE
SEARCH.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE ONLY THING
THAT IS IMPORTANT.
RIGHT NOW OUR EFFORTS ARE SOLELY
FOCUSED ON THE SEARCH.
THAT IS CERTAINLY A DIALOGUE
HAPPENING.
BUT WE'RE FOCUSED ON SEARCHING
AT THIS POINT.
>> IS THIS A RECOVERY OR A
RESCUE?
>> A SEARCH AND RESCUE 100%.
WE'RE SMACK DAB IN THE MIDDLE OF
A SEARCH AND RESCUE AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO PUT EVERY ASSET WE
HAVE TO FIND THE "TITAN" AND THE
CREW MEMBERS.
>> CAN YOU CONFIRM SOME SORT OF
RECTANGULAR OBJECT HAS BEEN
SPOTTED?
THERE WAS SOME SORT OF REPORT
ABOUT THAT.
>> SO A COUPLE THINGS.
THE ROVs, EACH ONE BRINGS
DIFFERENT CAPABILITY.
THE ROVs DIVING TODAY, WHAT IS
THE DEPTH?
YEP, 4,000 METERS.
AND ADDITIONAL ROVs ARRIVING
TOMORROW HAVE ADDITIONAL DEPTH
CAPABILITY.
WITH RESPECT TO AN OBJECT, SO
YESTERDAY, ONE OF THE AIRCRAFT
DID SEE AN OBJECT.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
IN SEARCH AND RESCUE MISSIONS
WHEN AIRCRAFT ARE FLYING
CONTINUOUSLY, THERE IS STUFF OUT
IN THE OCEAN THAT IS FLOATING.
WE WENT BACK AND LOOKED AT IT.
WE DIDN'T DETERMINE IT TO BE
DEBRIS.
WE DON'T THINK IT CORRELATES
WITH THE CASE AND IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON AT ALL DURING AN ACTIVE
SEARCH.
YOU SEE THINGS AND THEN YOU GO
LOOK AT THEM.
>> WHEN WERE THESE NOISES FIRST
HEARD?
DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION IN
TERMS OF FOOD AND WATER THAT THE
MEN MIGHT HAVE ON BOARD?
>> SO SEVERAL P-3 FLIGHTS HAVE
HEARD THE NOISES YESTERDAY AND
WE PUT ASSETS THERE.
WE RELOCATED ASSETS IMMEDIATELY.
WITH RESPECT TO FOOD AND WATER,
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THERE ARE
LIMITED RATIONS.
I CAN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY HOW
MUCH THEY HAVE ABOARD BUT THEY
DO HAVE SOME LIMITED RATIONS
ABOARD.
[ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ]
>> I THINK YOU NEED TO BE
CAREFUL.
WE NEED TO HAVE HOPE, RIGHT?
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THE
NOISES ARE.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU, AND I THINK
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
POINT.
WE'RE SEARCHING WHERE THE NOISES
ARE AND THAT'S ALL WE CAN DO AT
THIS POINT.
>> -- RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE
STATUS?
ARE THE NOISES CONTINUING NOW?
>> SO I JUST, IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THE P-3 HEARD
NOISES TODAY AS WELL.
I WANT TO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INVITE CARL TO THE PODIUM TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT, HE HAS
MORE EXPERTISE IN UNDERWATER
ACOUSTICS AND COMPLAIN TO SPEAK
TO THAT IN GENERAL.
THERE ARE NOISES BELOW THE
SURFACE OF THE OCEAN.
>> AGAIN, FROM THE OCEANOGRAPHIC
INSTITUTION.
THE ASSOCIATION A VERY COMPLEX
PLACE.
OBVIOUSLY HUMAN SOUNDS, NATURE
SOUNDS, AND IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO DISCERN WHAT THE SOURCE OF
THE NOISES ARE AT TIMES.
I CAN TELL THAT YOU THIS TEAM
HAS MULTIPLE SENSORS.
THEY'RE IN THE AREA.
THEY'RE SENDING DATA BACK
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO THE BEST IN THE
WORLD PEOPLE TO ANALYZE THAT
DATA AND THEN THEY'RE FEEDING
THE RESULTS BAG TO THE UNIFIED
TEAM AND THEY'RE MAKING
DECISIONS.
SO WE'RE HERE IN AN ADVISORY